you're passionate activist and a lot of
it is the well you call it the highway
platform tell us about that just quickly
because it's it's it's important it's
it's a platform that I started it's all
over the world and it's on the internet
it's called act i underscore way and
it's just a new way of valuing ourselves
I think we still live in a world where
we value women in particular just we we
measure their worth on a weighing scale
and I'm done with that because it's
almost 2020 damn it it's a mental health
movement that really moves against shame
and changes the way that we look at
ourselves and teaches us to be grateful
for our bodies and for our minds and so
it's this big old activism platform that
has helped me change policies on
Instagram and Facebook to protect minors
from being able to because they're not
people who work in mines people under
the age of protection as well tell them
what you do because you protect miners
from being exposed to detox and deities
and cosmetic surgery procedures on the
internet and then also I've recently
been speaking at the Senate in Boston
because we're trying to pass two bills
to protect young people and also
everyone from a photo shop but also be
diet and detox products let's get them
off the shelf away from teenagers I took
all that stuff when I was younger and
I'll never ever get better and so I'm
damned if it's gonna happen again
very good
[Applause]